[Musique]
il
ok
[Musique]
alexandre laval bonjour bonjour
véronique merci d'être ici sur le
plateau de tv soixante dix huit pour un
vip que l'on vous consacre entièrement
vous êtes ici parce que vous êtes
plusieurs choses vous êtes acteur vous
êtes auteur et vous êtes metteur en
scène et où c'est aussi yves binois
versaillais pour plus de précisions et
vous avez une actualité justement à
versailles donc tout ça c'est bon ce que
j'ai dit c'est vrai tout est bon qu'on
filme et je m'allonge bienvenus d'accord
en ce moment vous parle en ce moment
mais bientôt vous allez proposer des
visites théâtrales et des
représentations
on va y revenir un peu plus tard déjà
moi j'aimerais connaître votre parcours
quelle est votre formation d'acteur par
exemple alors d'acteurs jeu j'ai fait
une formation au conservatoire de
versailles
oui qui est ma ville de coeur et j'ai
bien fait pendant trois ans j'ai suivi
un cycle d'orientation professionnelle
qui a été vraiment immersif et
passionnant notamment avec des
représentations au théâtre montansier le
théâtre de la ville de versailles
et puis vous avez une deuxième passion
je crois oui l'histoire de l'art avant
le théâtre j'ai validé une licence
d'histoire de l'art avec un mémoire sur
les femmes peintres dits du xviiie
siècle dont on va on va reparler
oui et donc ensuite j'avais toujours le
théâtre au coeur et j'avais besoin de de
m'immerger à fond pendant trois années
donc après ses études d'histoire de
l'art je me suis inscrit à versailles au
conservatoire voilà et aujourd'hui vous
avez réussi à allier finalement ses deux
passions de pain aujourd'hui depuis
quelques années déjà parce que je crois
que votre premier spectacle sur madame
du barry c'était en 2015
oui même on peut dire 2014 bah disons
puisque dieu
denis gueule puisque c'est ça a été mon
projet de fin de cycle au conservatoire
alors dites moi un peu plus alors au
mois le thème alors c'était un choix
libre donc moi j'ai choisi d'écrire
d'écrire une pièce de tout créer de
l'écriture à la mise en scène même à la
aux dessins des costumes
est-ce que vous dessinez aussi je crois
oui d'accord sur madame du barry donc
c'est sur la scène centrale de la pièce
voilà la dernière favorite de louis 15
au destin tragique et donc romanesque
qui est propre à ailleurs à écrire une
pièce de théâtre qui m'inspire est
d'accord alors cette pièce elle a été
jouée ou alors elle a été elle a été
créée au théâtre montansier avec la
comédienne julia clavel que vous voyez
sur les clans nos écrans mais voilà qui
a qui a été salué par le jury donc il
m'a encouragé à la rejouer et nous
l'avons rejouer dans le cadre de la
programmation du mois molière en 2015 au
théâtre montansier et ensuite au
pavillon musique de louveciennes
pourquoi nous pourquoi elle ouvre alors
pourquoi louveciennes et bien parce que
madame du barry a vécu c'était son lieu
de villégiature corps et c'est un
endroit magnifique qui surplombe la
scène et donc on a on a joué cette pièce
dans l'endroit où madame du barry a vécu
c'est quelque chose qui qui m'importe de
créer vraiment d'immerger le spectateur
dans les lieux qui sont en lien avec les
personnages dont je raconte l'histoire
autant que faire se peut voilà et alors
justement voilà vous avez donc soit
cette capacité donc à 2 d'auteur à
écrire donc des pièces et aussi vous
proposer des visites théâtrales arts
sont deux concepts différents la vie
théâtrale c'est quoi alors la visite
théâtrale prenons président allait aller
sur le visuel que vous voyez donc cette
fois ci on est au grand palais dans
l'exposition consacrée à elisabeth
vigée-lebrun j'ai eu lieu fin 2015 début
2016 dont portraitiste attitré de
marie-antoinette qu'on peut voir sur sur
cette photo est donc la visite théâtrale
c'est simple c'est un comédien ici en
l'occurrence une comédienne qui incarne
un personnage en lien avec l'exposition
donc là la comédienne incarne
vigée lebrun et on a la chance d'avoir
les mémoires de madame vigée lebrun qui
raconte ses séances avec ses modèles
donc c'était merveilleux de pouvoir la
faire parler devant le public et donc la
comédienne incarne à 100% les
personnages et les coûts de matériaux
alors c'était une expérience
merveilleuse
ouais et du coup le spectateur visiteurs
et spectateurs à la fois est
complètement replonger dans dans le
xviiie à l'éminent l'atelier de
l'artiste
oui et puis on a un rapport aussi on a
eu beaucoup de retours enthousiastes du
public un rapport émotionnel qu'on n'a
pas forcément dans une visite classique
avec un conférencier fouet qui va axer
de manière scientifique sa visite nous
c'est vraiment sur le vous avez la
réincarnation de manga dollars de chair
et d'os devant vous et puis on prolonge
notre notre plaisir de comédiens
d'incarner tout simplement un personnage
on est tous les ingrédients sont là
finalement et plus qu'à allumer le feu
et hop les voilà l étincelle génial et
alors pour parler de l'avenir proche
donc des visites théâtrales sont prévues
au musée lambinet ici nous avions reçu
xavier mathieu le commissaire de
l'exposition antonio de la gandara qui a
toujours lieu au musée lambinet donc à
portraitiste de la belle époque le
gentilhomme peintres de la belle époque
donc vous vous proposez dans le même
temps la même optique des visites
théâtrales au musée lambinet voilà en
tenu de l'acompte arras et vous alors
voilà je me suis plu à incarner ce
personnage oui oui je sais c'est
passionnant d'incarner un peintre oui
à l'appel et décider en plus voilà well
tous tout se rejoint
bon j'ai la chance d'avoir une petite
ressemblance physique même si j'ai
laissé pousser la moustache pour lequel
oui ça aide aussi
ouais et ce peintre qui malheureusement
est tombé dans l'oubli a été très
célèbres de son temps monsieur mathieu
on a très bien dans notre émission et
donc je j'ai retrouvé les interviews
qu'il a données aux journalistes de son
temps dans la presse
et j'en ai fait la matière de la visite
théâtrale avec aussi un liant qui est
mon écriture personnelle pour que tout
soit le plus fluide possible quand vous
allez à 6 2 le petit salon un petit
salon dans le musée lambinet qu'il est
un hôtel particulier donc vierge entre
nati mois la rési l'artiste fait visiter
en quelque sorte son atelier à ses
intimes
donc c'est une impression extraordinaire
finalement hors du commun je l'espère
alors deuxième concept c'est à dire la
pièce créée en fonction de l'exposition
peut dire ça ou pas c'est une création
comment elle s'appelle cette pièce alors
elle s'appelle elle s'intitule le
pinceau de la belle époque et se
concentre sur l'histoire de ce peintre
j'ai voulu le faire connaître aussi de
manière plus large au public c'est aussi
sa vie peut-être privé aussi j'ai été
inspiré par le portrait la dame en bleu
qu'on voit sur la fiche du spectacle km
dames en bleu voilà qui était la fille
naturelle de l'artiste avec une
comédienne bien et l'atr de l'odéon vous
donc on plonge le spectateur dans le
paris de la belle époque du théâtre des
arts on parle de sarah bernhardt de
proust donc de robert de modestie de
robert de montesquiou qui était son ami
et son directeur et mécène voilà et donc
oui le matériau pareil est très riche
qu'il ya vraiment de quoi
mais cela reste une histoire qu'on
raconte l'histoire de floris donc de
cette dame en bleu dans une époque où
les femmes étaient encore assez corsetée
donc ça permet de raconter sa vie à elle
oui et c'est une femme qui est qui a
vécu à versailles tout à fait qui a vécu
à versailles qui fera son entrée à me
judith floria tosca d'accord c'est on
nous a mis des graviers gravier voilà le
rêve c'est un auteur de théâtre d'accord
charles johannes gravité elle avait
elle-même des velléités théâtrale alors
oui j'ai imaginé j'avais avec tripoli
mais là c'est quand même la fille d'une
d'une comédienne son troisième prénom
c'est la tosca en référence à la pièce
de sardou qui inspire et l'opéra de
puccini mais qui n'ont été créés à sa
naissance
d'accord et par hasard je suppose voilà
et puis aux rockets on a aussi des
musiques dans le spectacle qui replonge
dans cette ambiance vous avez donc vous
avez en fait constitué une compagnie
créée une compagnie chatons ont dit non
pas des mois la compagnie du chapeau
taille alors le chapeau de paille c'est
une référence à madame du barry je crois
oui à son accessoire fétiche à la peau
de paille aussi à la pièce de labiche
qui est très connu puis c'est un
accessoire qui me parle que je trouve
convivial soleil
et le théâtre c'est un peu ça assez
emmené le public en villégiature avec
nous d'accord on des vacances voilà
s'échapper donc votre compagnie elle est
actuellement
en résidence quelque part
la continuité serais je l'espère
d'obtenir une résidence à versailles qui
est une ville qui nous qui nous inspire
qui inspire le sud rail de la compagnie
et à laquelle vous avez joué des pièces
d'eau lors du mois molière de fait nos
différents lieux dans versailles
bibliothèque de versailles qui est
magnifique
donc à mon attention on l'a dit et l'a
fait cette pièce donc et tout tout
fraîchement créé finalement parce
qu'elle n'a pas encore été joué non la
première aura lieu quand le dimanche 27
janvier
d'accord à 15 heures 30 dans
l'auditorium du musée accès à
l'intérieur du musée
encore une fois et il y aura deux
représentations de représentation
d'accord de la deuxième que vrillé à
15h30
de même que les visites théâtrales pour
s'inscrire il suffit de regarder balassa
s'affiche sur notre écran c'est juste
génial c'est moi la magnifique suffit
d'appeler le musée et et on s'inscrit
voila voila comme il est c'est destiné à
quel public en fait parce qu'on peut
imaginer je trouve que ce côté très
vivant très très humain que vous donnez
peut plaire à des enfants ou peut-être
des adolescents et en mange bien je
pense que vous le verrez bleus de
travailler avec des d'aidé scolaire
oui avec grand plaisir j'avais eu
l'occasion de france ça j'avais eu
l'occasion de donner d une visite
théâtrale dans l'exposition sur les fans
de la révolution musée lambinet puisque
c'est au programme
parce que vous aviez travaillé aussi au
moment de cette exposition les femmes de
l'amazone de la révolution voilà vous
aviez écrit pièce alors j'avais adapté
les mémoires de
manon roland voilà qui était une femme
passionnante de la révolution engagé
littéraire donc c'est intéressant pour
le jeune public de je pense de leur
donner goût à l'histoire d'une manière
immersive et hatim et émotionnelle voyez
ouais ok bon ben écoutez très bien la
bonne chance on espère que cette pièce
va rencontrer beaucoup de succès qu'elle
va vivre après dans d'autres lieux
donc je redonne son titre le pinceau de
la belle époque
inspiré de l'avis d'antonio la gandara
et de sa petite fille flora floris pour
les intimes floris pour les intimes
fille naturelle
voilà et les visites théâtrales qui
m'ont tenu en janvier en france janvier
en février jusqu'à la fin de
l'exposition qui permettent de plonger
dans le monde du peintre voilà voilà
mais écoutez alex en aval un grand merci
merci à vous véronique et plein de
succès merci et à bientôt à bientôt
[Musique]